ni procès pour crimes de guerre s'ouvre
donc aujourd'hui en ukraine celui d'un
soldat russe de 21 ans il est accusé
d'avoir abattu en civils non armés près
de soumis au début de l'invasion russe à
kiev les précisions de gulliver craag
notre correspondant
c'est un procès qui doit s'ouvrir
aujourd'hui avec vadim chessy marine un
jeune soldat russe de 21 ans qui dans la
région de soumis aurait tué un civil un
villageois un honneur mais il est accusé
donc de ce meurtre lui probablement
essayera de se défendre avec son avocat
qui a été nommé par le gouvernement
ukrainien en disant qu'il ne faisait que
suivre des autres bien sûr c'est un
procès qui sera suivi très attentivement
à part les médias ukrainiens et
internationale